let's start by going back to 2021 when
the pandemic was still raging covid-19
restrictions were still in place and it
was the leading cause of death claiming
000 lives today it is a very different
picture covid-19 is no longer in the top
five we may be looking for it less
testing less and it is still significant
it is still deadly 22
000 deaths over the course of last year
the question is whether that's the new
normal or whether it will come down over
time now though dementor Alzheimer's is
the biggest killer followed by heart
diseases it's worth noting that both
these are killing more people than they
did in 2021 and earlier this year sir
Chris Whitty warned we'd have a
prolonged period of excess deaths due to
the pandemic because of delays in
treatment while the country was in
lockdown we may be seeing some of that
in the data now this chart shows excess
deaths over the last 70 years the line
across there shows how much higher they
are than we'd specs compared to the
previous five years not including 2020
and 21 because of the pandemic deaths
are 6.2 percent higher than the average
that is an extra 33
747 people who died last year more than
we'd expect now the UK isn't alone here
this shows the number of excess deaths
across Europe in the second half of 2022
and you can see that Germany Spain Italy
they all experience relatively High
excess mortality France the odd one out
just dipping below there now exactly why
that's happening we don't know it's
probably likely a combination of things
to start with we have a growing and
aging population so more people would
die but even accounting for that it's
still higher than it probably should be
next question is well how much is the
effect of covid-19 both in terms of
postponed treatment as Chris whissy was
warning but also the diseases long-term
effects on the General Health of the
population how much perhaps is an
overstretched NHS and how long are
excess deaths likely to remain high and
the ons is looking into these questions
so are other organizations and it's
vital to understand the reasoning each
percentage Point difference on those
charts represents thousands of lives
saved or thousands Gone Too Soon